jones et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur cela dit hobbies enfin avec
bic a ici présents en rose on est sur
scène petit the bees 2 parce que on peut
jouer en co op joysticks c'est peut-être
un peu plus marrant voilà alors le but
du jeu ici c'est de retrouver des bols
de riz dans ce mode de jeu tv coach v
clic droit tu vois loin avec ta caméra
gens c'est clair beaucoup plus mais
pourquoi j'aurais ya deux secondes temps
on va voir si j'arrive à 0 - 0
ma caméra n'a plus de batterie c'est
tout ça m'a fait peur quand tu es passé
un petit script heures mais je sais quoi
certains ou telle à louga ont des
attentes car tu vois ccba nourrit là
qu'il faut ramasser cela alors temps
j'ai peur j'entendais bruit mais qu
advient il faut dépasser qui sais-je en
mai 2007
je prends un pôle piri weepu badouri
s'est attaché à ne me fait pas peur et
jambes me lâche
allez mika on affronte le danger un peu
non attends je crois que c'est pas tout
mais [ __ ] moi j'ai eu peur sur le chu
morbide javaugue mais non je suis décédé
c'est un abandon forcé est comme suit me
perds pas de vue que j'étais handicapé
c'est quoi cette pluie qu'on va dire
d'un [ __ ] de peinture qu'un mec
s'amuse à nous jeter sur la gueule et
bataillon mais qu'a fait qu'un tueur
volet reviens mon amour
à l'est la vieille blague ou quoi déjà
la vase il bouge par bush pavesi bouge
ça arrête de bouger à deux boules en
bois alors bas alors tu es bayat ont pas
dit oui au passé c'est pas moi c'est pas
mon nom mais j'insiste et je te dirai
pas sauter canon s'est pas laissé le
temps s'était porté sur nous maintenant
mais dieu si les bras mais arrêtez de
faire sauter nathan mais ou sur les
boîtes de riz quoi temps
oui tu entends ce bruit n'ont d'autant
pas le bruit j'entends taille à lyon qui
prend des contrats d'armes quoi elle ce
mec va vraiment table tout le québec est
en train de se toucher non mais non mais
non mais ça cesse dans ta tête c'est ton
tour tu as fait ça un bol un bol de riz
je me suis là le truc et bleu il faut
brider les fonds et un problème moi je
suis derrière toi cependant mes données
chez sa mère et part je suis là c'est
bon on a peur on dirait que c'était 40
par son pied col.red
il est plus là n'est plus là mais en
tant que gratter les plus bénins ne
sentirez oui ah oui je sentirai il est
plus là avey tare est si je le voyais
que la cam se voit en regard de mes
attentes et voilà il va décider quoi il
ya là bas tu m'as fait stop tumeur au 20
juin au change
on change de marque stand ea kraft tu
l'as vu le médecin à temps je vois je
vois c'est mon copain
non non non mais mika mikado
c'est bon la semaine et sur mac c'est
pour garder on les embête pour y aller
attends je vais faire un petit truc tu
es où je peux remonter haut au mec quoi
il m'a tuer regarde au dolce à mika tu
es tu es vivant
mika inutile imiter un poisson on change
de maps des urgences de maths mais je ne
sens pas du tout chaque porte c'est toi
+ moi mais si tu commences à temps mais
avec quatre jours il est là regarde il
montre ses fesses date as well as well
as et soeurs de ninja avec un sabre et
près 1-1 3-3 et lucas qui m'a coupé la
tête coincée là je vais je suis à
limoges la mission s'avère un peu trop
baban terminée l'allemand il ya un loup
qui va jouer le méchant je pense
je suis bloqué un schéma je t'attaque
une armée mecs savent que trop au
sérieux
achetez voyait courir avec des petites
tailles mais qu'a déjà j'étais pris un
coup de tonnerre toit de mourir
j'apprends maintenant un bon moi je peux
bien matt été fait ici ça fait très
plaisir autour de toi je te dis vite
fait mais je ne mets et les vins rogard
batteur mais cette scène est ridicule
ouais tu mets un super pote je vous
renvoie à voir maintenant si tu me
trouves quand tu spawn je te respecte
voilà à mon nouveau marqueur des normes
oui je sais contracter mais je crois
qu'il est mort deux blessés décédés et à
dire lui donc barrière labaye un
excellent bouquin oui on n'approche pas
alors oui j'ai mal dormi
je préfère ça le bug de la map
ravaillac escalade
oui nos batailles à que nous pour faire
ce à quoi la sévère 2 et sentir de
descendre à temps la carotte les arbres
sont transparents bâton mais fait quoi
et je vois un des trois soleils mince
espace commun
mais son crédo libre quoi avec un
registre est cette fois il a redit
surtout son immeuble mon gars auraient
fait mon garde moi il sut bruit attend
mondiale vient laver d'un côté de
l'autre vanessa y rien à te revient à
notre bol terrible à vas-y ap la même
litanie fier dans mes codes le col
attend c'est bon je crois qu'il l'a
attends attends attends c'est quoi ce
vieux gladu vie mais c'est pas un bug
oui mais quand tu vois si la boîte de
riz l'agencé de la fin de cette vidéo
sur ce qui est dit biz de accompagné de
1000 cas ici présents sous moi en train
de faire absolument rien j'espère que
vous aurez pu si c'est le cas elle ne
s'était pas vu la vidéo ça me fait un
grand plaisir et ça lui fera plaisir ou
pas le cas ça fait extrêmement plus
jaoui j'aime bien en gage
j'ai fait de voir des rebelles qui
regroupe les balad'ours quoi on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat au monde
[Musique]